Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to do this and this and
this on a budget.
Today, through the power of computer graphics
research works, we can simulate all these
amazing elastic interactions.
If we are very patient that is, because they
take forever to compute.
But, if we wish to run these simulations quicker,
what we can is increasing something that we
call the time step size.
Usually, this means that the simulation takes
less time, but is also less accurate.
Let’s see this phenomenon through a previous
method from just a year ago.
Here, we set the time step size relatively
small, and drop an elastic barbarian ship
onto these rods.
And this is a challenging scene because the
ship is made out of half a million tiny elements,
and we have to simulate their interactions
with the scene.
How does this perform?
Uh-oh.
This isn’t good.
Did you see the issues?
Issue number one is that the simulation is
unstable.
Look.
Things remain in motion when they shouldn’t.
And two, this is also troubling.
Penetrations.
Now, let’s increase the time step size.
What do we expect to happen?
Well, now, we advance the simulation in bigger
chunks, so we should expect to miss even more
interactions in between these bigger steps.
And…whoa!
Sure enough.
Even more instability, even more penetration.
So, what is the solution?
Well, let’s have a look at this new method
and see if it can deal with this difficult
scene.
Now, hold on to your papers, and…wow, I
am loving this.
Issue number one, things coming to rest is
solved, and, issue number two, no penetrations.
That is amazing.
Now, what is so interesting here?
Well, what you see here should not be possible
at all, because this new technique computes
a reduced simulation instead.
This is a simulation on a budget.
And not only that, but let’s increase the
time step size a little.
This means that we can advance the time when
in bigger chunks when computing the simulation,
at the cost of potentially missing important
interactions between these steps.
Expect a bad simulation now, like with the
previous one, and…wow, this is amazing.
It still looks fine.
But we don’t know that for sure, because
we haven’t seen the reference simulation
yet.
So, you know what’s coming.
Oh yes!
Let’s compare it to the reference simulation
that takes forever to compute.
This looks great.
And, let’s see… this looks great too.
They don’t look the same, but if I were
asked which one reference is, and which is
the cheaper, reduced simulation, I am not
sure if I would be able to tell.
Are you able to tell?
Well, be careful with your answer, because
I have swapped the two.
In reality, this is the reference, and this
is the reduced simulation.
Were you able to tell?
Let me know in the comments below.
And that is exactly the point!
All this means that we got away with only
computing the simulation in bigger steps.
So, why is that good?
Well, of course, we get through it quicker!
Okay, but how much quicker?
110 times quicker.
What?
The two are close to equivalent, but this
is more than a 100 times quicker?
Sign me up, right away!
Note that this is still not real time, but
we are firmly in the seconds per frame domain,
so we don’t need an all nighter for such
a simulation, just a coffee break.
Now note that this particular scene is really
suited for the new technique, other scenes
aren’t typically a hundred times faster,
but, worst case scenario is when we throw
around a bunch of furballs, but even that
is at least ten to fifteen times faster.
What does that mean?
Well, an all-nighter simulation can be done
maybe not during a coffee break, but during
a quick little nap.
Yes, we can rest like this tiny dinosaur for
a while, and by the time we wake up, the simulation
is done, and we can count on it being close
to the real deal.
So good!
Just make sure to keep the friction high while
resting here, or otherwise…this happens.
So, from now on, we get better simulations,
up to a hundred times faster.
What
a time to be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!